The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SHIMON ULLMAN: Now for a
different, entirely different
type of issue that
has more to do
with recognition, some
psychophysics, some computer
vision.
But you will see at the end
the motivation was really
to be able to, be
able to recognize
and understand really
complicated things that are
happening in natural images.
Now, when we look at
objects in the world,
people have worked a lot
in object recognition,
and we can recognize
well complete objects,
but we can also recognize a
very limited configuration
of objects.
So we are very good at
using limited information
if this is what's
available in order
to recognize what's in there.
And this is some
arbitrary collection.
I guess you can
recognize all of them.
Some of them, if you think
about a person or even a face--
this is a very small
part of a face--
everybody I guess knows
what it is, right?
It's not even a recognizable,
well-delineated part
like an eye.
You see a part of a person here.
We know what it is, right?
I mean, everybody
recognizes this, and so on.
Now, I think that
the ability to be
able to get all the information
out even from a limited region
plays an important role
in understanding images.
And let me motivate
it by one example.
I'll go back to it at the end.
When we look at these images,
we know what's happening.
We know what the action here is.
All the people are
performing the same action.
They are all drinking, even
drinking from a bottle, right?
But the images as images
are very different.
If you look at each image,
if you stored one image
and you try to recognize another
image based on the first one,
it will be difficult. The
variability here can be huge.
But if you focus on
where the action really
takes place, the most
informative part where
most of the answer is already
given to you of what's
happening here, which is
where the bottle is docked
into the mouth, you can see
that now these diverse images
becomes virtually almost
a copy of one another,
almost the same.
So if you manage to
understand this and extract
the most informative
part, although it's
limited and so on,
the variability
will be much, much reduced.
The variability here
is much, much reduced
compared to the variability that
you have in the entire image.
So most of the other stuff
is much less relevant,
but this is where the
information is concentrated.
And in the limited,
restricted configuration,
recognition will be much easier,
and will generalize much better
from one situation
to another because
of this principle of
highly-reduced variability
in the delimited image.
So we became interested.
As you see, it's useful.
But it's also-- to deal
with small images and still
recognize the limited images,
you'll see it's much more--
there are some very
challenging issues.
And I want to discuss
it a little bit,
and then also discuss what it's
good for a little bit more.
I will show you
some human studies.
What we wanted to
see is what are
the minimal images that
people can still recognize.
We examined some computational
models, and I will give you--
will not keep the secret.
It turns out that
well-performing current
schemes, including
deep networks,
cannot deal well with
such minimal images.
And, from this, I want to
discuss some implications
in terms of representations in
our system, brain processing,
and things like this.
And quite a number of people
have been involved in this.
Here are the names.
Some of them are in the
Weizmann Institute in Israel,
and a few that--
Leyla is here.
Leyla Isik, she is here in the
summer school, and a student,
Yena Han, at MIT doing
some brain imaging
on this, which I will
mention very briefly.
So I'll start with
the human study.
We are looking for minimal
atomic things in recognition,
and the experiment
goes like this.
You show a subject an image
and ask them to recognize it,
just produce a label.
So this is a dog.
If they say a dog,
they recognize it.
And if they recognize
it correctly,
we generate five descendants
from this initial image.
If this image was,
say, 50 by 50 pixels--
and I'll tell you about
pixels in a minute.
But say it's 50 by 50 pixels.
We make it somewhat smaller.
We reduce use it, because
it's still not minimal.
And we reduce it in five ways.
We either copy it at
one of the four corners
to create, say, a 48
by 48 image by taking
two pixels from
this corner here,
or this corner here, and so
on and so forth descendants.
And we generate-- we
also take the full image.
Keep it as is.
We do not crop it.
We just reduce the resolution.
So we resample it so some
details start to become lost.
Instead of 50 by 50 pixels, it's
also a full image but 48 by 48.
And then we give each
one of these images--
now we have five.
We give each one-- this is
beginning to expand as a tree.
Each one of the five is
given again to a subject.
If they recognize it,
again five descendants
are being generated, and
we explore the entire tree
until we find all
the sub-images which
are minimal and
can be recognizable
in this original configuration.
Now, this is challenging
psychophysically
in terms of number of
subjects, because we
use a subject only once.
Because if you
show a subject this
and he recognizes
it, if you show him
the same subject,
a reduced image,
he will recognize the image
based on his previous exposure.
So you don't you do not
want to use him again.
So you don't use him again,
and you show the other images
to a new subject.
And this requires a
large number of subjects.
So 15,000 subjects
participated in this experiment
online by Mechanical Turk,
together with some laboratory
controls to see that they
are doing the right thing,
and how it compares with
the same experiment done
under laboratory
conditions, and so on.
So the way we define the
minimal image for recognition
is in this tree.
Here is an image.
This image is recognizable.
And then we create
the five descendants,
and none of the descendants
is recognizable.
So this is recognizable.
Nothing here is recognizable.
So it's minimal because
you can no longer reduce it
either by resolution going
here or by reducing the size.
Any manipulation like this
will make it unrecognizable.
Technically, when
I'm-- in my measuring,
if I'm using numbers that
the image is 50 pixels or 35
pixels, and so, it's
actually well-defined.
I mean not the
pixels on the screen.
You can take the image and
make it bigger or smaller
on the screen.
But the number of sampling
points in the image
is well-defined.
When you give me an
image, a particular image,
I can tell you how many sample
points you need in order
to capture this image.
Technically, for those of you
who know it, it's twice the--
if you do a Fourier transform
and take twice the cutoff
frequency, the highest frequency
in the Fourier spectrum,
this is, by the sampling
theorem of Shannon,
this is the number of
points you need in order to.
So when I said that the
image was 35 pixels,
I don't really care.
You can make it somewhat
smaller or larger
on the screen by interpolation.
It doesn't change the
information content.
It's well-defined
notion mathematically
how many points, discrete
points or sampling
points in these images.
So a very interesting
thing that we
found when we found
these minimal images
is that there is a
sharp transition when
you get to the level
of the minimal images.
So you go down and
you recognize it.
And then there is
a sharp transition
that it suddenly becomes
unrecognizable, basically,
to the large majority of people.
So it can change a little bit,
and I'll show you some examples
for you to try to see how
these minimal images look
like at the recognizable
level, at the unrecognizable.
This is the recognizable level.
This is the
unrecognizable level.
So to show it to you
as examples here,
I will show you first
the unrecognizable one,
the one which people
find, on average, more
difficult to recognize.
And if you recognize
it, raise your hand.
Don't say what you
see, because this
will influence other people.
Just raise your hand if
you recognize the image.
And then I'll show you
the more recognizable one,
and let's see if
more hands show up,
if the distinction between the
recognizable and unrecognizable
holds here.
I'll just show you a couple
of examples from the--
OK, so I'll.
OK, so this is the
one which is supposed
to be difficult to recognize.
If you see what it is, if
you know what's the object,
raise your hand.
OK, good.
OK, don't say what it is.
We have two.
Let's see here.
OK, certainly more hands.
What do you see?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: Should I say it?
SHIMON ULLMAN: OK.
Now you can say it because--
AUDIENCE: A horse.
SHIMON ULLMAN: A horse.
Right.
So let me show
them side by side.
So you see that
it's very difficult
to recognize what's not recog--
this is, you can
see the statistic.
This is recognized by
93% of the subjects.
30 subjects saw each
one of these images.
93% recognized this.
3% recognized this.
And you look at
the image and you
see that they are
very similar images,
and it drops from 90% to 3%.
So you can see the two images,
and you can see the similarity,
and you can see the large drop.
This is part of the entire
tree which is being explored.
This is the farther.
This is the recognized one.
The minimal image.
And you can see that even reduce
the resolution, which is really
not a big manipulation, but
this is a drop in performance.
And you can see all the--
so we used 50% as our criterion.
So the parents should
be recognized at higher.
This should be
recognized at lower.
But typically the
jump is very sharp.
Let's try two more or
something just for fun.
If you can recognize
it, raise your hand.
OK.
Nobody, just for the record.
Look around.
You can see many.
What do you see?
AUDIENCE: A boat.
SHIMON ULLMAN: A boat.
Right.
So you can see the two images.
So 80% on this.
0% here.
And you can see that
what's really missing here
is the tip here.
And, clearly, this tip is--
there are many
contours in this image,
but this particular corner sharp
makes an enormous difference,
and it goes from 80% to 0%.
OK, let me skip.
Just one more.
OK, let me skip this.
This is somewhat easier.
OK.
This is some--
OK, at least one,
two, and three.
OK.
How about this one?
Everybody, I think.
Or maybe we are missing one.
So, again, you can see that
the difference-- if you
look at the two,
there is a difference,
and it's this thing here.
But it's not a very
big part of the image.
It's crucial, you know.
You have to be trained on this.
It's part of your
representation.
It's important.
You go from almost
90% to 15%, roughly.
So it's important.
So you can see that the drop
is typically very, very sharp.
And it's also-- the sharp
transition is also interesting,
in the sense that if it
drops from, like the horse,
from 90% to 3%, or
even here, it also
says that we all carry
around in our head
a very similar presentation.
Because if each one of
us, based on the history
and visual experience,
would be less or more
sensitive to various
features, then we
will not find this
sharp transition.
Different people will lose
it at different points
in the manipulation.
But at 90%, 90% of the
people, roughly everybody
recognizes it.
You remove a feature
and it goes to 3%.
So everybody is using the
same, or very similar,
representation, which I find
somewhat surprising, at least
for some of these images.
We don't all have the
same kind of experience
with horses, or with
battleships, or things
like that, and still
the representation
is very strikingly similar
across individuals.
The experiment was done
on 10 different objects.
These are the initial objects.
I showed you the object at the
beginning of the hierarchy,
and then you start the
manipulation to discover all
the minimal images inside them.
And here, so we ended up
with a very nice catalog.
We have a database of
all the minimal images
in all of these 10 images
in all of the children,
the unrecognizable ones.
So, in terms of
modeling and in terms
of exploring visual features
and what is necessary in order
to recognize, and so on,
there is a very rich data
set here of all
the minimal images
in all of these 10 images.
Here are some more pairs
of recognizable and
unrecognizable.
We already saw
this in principle,
but just to show some--
in some cases, it's pretty
clear what may be going on.
For example, this is horse legs,
the front legs of the horse.
This seems to be important.
You can see that very
often it's a tremendously
small-- in this fly image,
very small differences,
very hard to pinpoint.
And it's glass that you've
got in the eyeglasses.
Something here is
missing a little bit.
But very small things
in a very reliable way
cause this dramatic change.
As was mentioned here,
somebody mentioned, said
the inflection and point, you
can manipulate psychophysically
a bit more.
For example, here, this
was another version
of a minimal image.
It was cropped at two locations.
You can crop only
the left side, or you
can crop only the bottom
side, and you can try
to see what makes a difference.
So you can really zoom in
on the critical features.
In terms of number of
pixels, the impression
is that it's surprisingly small.
So I guess you can recognize
that this is an eagle.
This is an airplane.
And the number of pixels--
those of you who know
vision, your retina
has 120 million pixels.
The fovea, which is the area of
very high acuity, is 2 degrees.
It's about 250 by
250, 250 by 200 pixel.
This is the area at the
center, an area of high acuity.
But you can recognize
things with, I don't know,
15, 20 pixels.
It's 1/10 of your fovea.
It's tiny, tiny.
You can make it
larger, but in terms
of how much visual
information, I
find it surprising that
you need very, very little.
It's also interesting that
it's very useful, in the sense
that it's very redundant.
If you have the capacity, if
you have a visual system that
can recognize individually each
one of these minimal images,
and in fact they can be
recognized on their own,
then a full image like
this contains a high number
of partially overlapping
minimal images.
Some of them are large.
You can see each one of
these frame, colored frame,
is a minimal image,
shown not necessarily
at the right resolution.
You can reduce the
resolution of things.
But you can see that some
images are essentially
low-resolution representations
of the entire object,
like almost the entire eagle.
But some of them just
contain something
relatively small around
the head and the eye.
For the eye region,
you can see that you
can get a low-resolution, again,
thing of almost everything.
But just the corner
of the eye and things
like that are enough.
We find, in general, it
seems that things that
are related to humans,
you have a large number
of these minimal images.
So they provide a sensitive
tool to compare representations
to see what's missing
in the sub-image which
made the image become
unrecognizable.
So we call them
sometimes, these are
called minimal
recognizable configuration.
We call them configuration
but not images.
Not parts.
Not objects because
they are not objects.
And not parts because, as
we saw in the examples,
they do not have to be
well-delineated parts.
They are more like
local configuration.
But, anyway, minimal images.
The next thing
that we did is, we
were wondering if this kind
of behavior, the ability
to recognize these images
from such minimal information
requires-- it places
an interesting
challenge, or an interesting
test of a recognition system,
because you really
have to extract and use
all the available information.
By definition, this is minimal.
If you do not use all
the information that's
in this minimal
image, then you don't
have the minimal information.
You have less than
that and you will fail.
So a system that
is not good enough
will fail on these minimal
images, or the ability
to recognize them means that
you really can suck out all
the relevant information out.
So we were wondering what
will happen if we show it
to various computational
algorithms that performed well
on full images.
What will happen when
you challenge them
with things which
are, by nature,
designed to be non-redundant?
So here is what I will do.
It's not a computer
vision school.
I will not go too much
through the details
of the computational
schemes, just
to show you what was happening.
And the bottom line is that
they are not doing a good job.
Two things happen.
First of all, when you train
a computational system,
you do not see the same
drop that you see here,
that it recognizes one and
doesn't recognize the other.
You don't have a
drop in recognition.
This sort of phase
transition that
characterizes the
human vision system
is not reproduced in any of the
current recognition systems,
including deep network
and any other ones.
And, secondly, they are not
very good at recognizing them.
Regardless of the gap, that
there is a sharp transition
or not, they do not get
good recognition results
on these minimal images.
They do not suck all the
necessary information.
So in the full
images, it's like we
had an image of a
side view of a plane.
So we are training on airplane.
You can think of a deep network.
We actually tried a whole
range of good classifiers.
And in all of these
good classifiers--
those of you who
are not in vision
probably got enough at the
beginning of this summer school
that they have a feeling for a
classifier in computer vision.
It's a system, an algorithm,
a system, a scheme,
that you give it
training images.
You don't have to specify, you
don't tell it what to look for.
You just give it lots
of images and tell them
all these are of the same class.
And then it calibrates itself,
and adjusts parameters,
and so on.
And then you give it new
images, and the system
is supposed to tell you if it's
a new member of the same class
or not.
So, in this case,
we train the system,
giving them full side
views of an airplane.
But then we gave
them just the tails.
Compared to random pictures
taken from known images,
the question is do they
reliably can tell you
that this is a tail
of an airplane, part
of the previous class?
Or they would be
confused and they
will give even higher score
to things which do not
come from airplane at all?
So we started this when
deep networks were still not
the leaders, and we had
some other things, like DPM,
and including HMAX,
which is a very
good model of the human visual
system and performs very well.
And so we included it as well,
and deep network as well.
This is the HMAX.
This is convolutional
neural networks.
You probably got the idea,
it's just worth pointing,
I find it interesting in the
computer vision community
that you have Olympic
games every year.
It's something which is
very structured and very
competitive, and very
nice in this regard,
that there is the
Pascal challenge,
and the ImageNet challenge,
and it's well run.
And people who think
that they have a better
algorithm than others
can submit an entry,
can submit an algorithm.
Everybody gets training images
that are distributed publicly,
but there are secret
images used for testing.
And you can train your
algorithm on the available data.
Everybody uses the same data.
And then you submit
your algorithm,
and the algorithm is run by the
central committee on the test
images.
And the results are published,
and everybody knows who's
number one, who's number two.
You have the gold medal
and the silver medal.
It's very competitive,
and in some sense
it's doing very good things.
It's sort of driving
the performance up.
It also has some
negative effects,
I think, on the way
things are being done.
One negative is
it's very difficult
to come up with an
entirely new scheme which
explores a completely new idea.
Because, initially,
before you fine tune it,
it will not be at the level of
the high-performing winners,
and until it establishes
itself as a winner,
it will not get credit.
So it sort of becomes a
little bit conservative
in this regard, which
is the unfortunate part.
So, as I told you, and I
will not go in great detail,
the two basic outcomes
is that the gap
between the recognizable and
recognizable-- these two bars
are the gap for human vision.
That's the whole
group of horse images.
The parents are
highly recognizable.
The children, the offsprings,
are not recognizable.
Very large drop.
This drop is not
recaptured in this model,
in any of the model.
If you have a deep
network, or you
have one of these
classifiers, what
is recognized and not recognized
depends on the threshold.
You can decide that.
It gives you a
number, and it says
that I have this
and this confidence
that this belongs to the class.
So what we did here is
that we tried to match.
We had a class of images,
and people recognized them
at 80% recognition.
So we put the threshold in the
artificial, the computer vision
system, at such a level
that it recognized correctly
80% of the minimal images.
So you match them.
And then we looked at how
many of the sub-images
passed the threshold.
And you get-- this
is for deep network--
that, instead of a gap, you
actually got an anti-gap.
It actually
recognized a few more.
But this should not confuse you.
It does not mean that the deep
network did better than humans.
It actually did much
worse than humans,
although the bars
here are higher.
And the reason is the following.
You can always, even in
a very bad classifier,
you can get 80% recognition by
just lowering the threshold,
and then 80% of
the class examples
will exceed the threshold.
The question is how
many just garbage image,
non-class images, will also pass
the threshold at the same time.
If you get 80% of the
class but also lots
and lots and lots of
completely false positive,
negative images,
non-class images
are also saying I'm an airplane,
then that's bad performance.
So just these high bars
do not say anything.
The actual recognition
levels were very low.
We can see here
for deep networks
that this high bar is the
performance on new airplanes.
So for airplanes
it did very well.
But the percent correct that
it did on minimal images
were 3%, or 4%, were
very, very, very low.
So it did very bad recognition
on the minimal images.
So recognition of
minimal images does not
emerge by training any
of the existing models
that I know in the world,
including deep network models.
Now, the second test
was, as was asked here,
is that we did
another large test.
All of these things,
actually, were a lot of effort
and time-consuming.
Because now we have this.
This was in the original
test, was a minimal image.
I don't know if this
was a minimal image.
Then we collected a
range of tails of planes
like this for many
other airplanes.
And we ran another
Turk experiment, which
was pretty large
because we wanted
to verify that each one of
these patches that we added
to our test and we were going
to use for testing recognition,
was indeed a minimal
image for recognition.
So each one of these patches,
and there were 60 of those,
we ran psychophysically.
And we saw that
it's recognizable,
and if you make it small,
if you try to reduce it,
it's unrecognizable.
So each one of these
is individually
also a minimal image.
So here we did training
and testing on--
so this is some
examples of this.
So here are various images
of fly, and each one of them
was tested on 30 subjects
on the Mechanical Turk.
And the results are that, in
terms of correct recognition,
there is a substantial
improvement from 3% to 60%.
But 60% is not very large.
People recognized them--
I should say you should
look at the false alarm.
The number of errors,
I will show you later.
The number of errors
that, even after training
on minimal images, the
performance of the deep network
and all the other models
on the minimal images
is far worse than
human recognition
levels, human performance,
on the same image.
So it's not just the
gap is not reproduced.
Even training with
minimal images,
the performance
is not reproduced.
The errors, or the
accuracy, is far worse
in all the models,
including deep network,
compared to human vision.
So these systems do not do it.
It remains to be--
you can always ask,
what happens if I train it
with 100,000 images and I add
and add more and more examples?
This we couldn't-- this
becomes more and larger.
But with the
experiments we've done,
which are quite
extensive, it does not
begin to approach
human accuracy.
Humans are much better.
And I'll show you.
I think it's not just a
competition, who does better.
I think there is
something deeper there.
And that's what I
want to go next.
Let me skip some.
These are the error comparison.
And you can see, just as we saw,
in a lot of different examples,
0 errors for humans, 17%
error in the deep networks,
and so on.
So those are big differences.
OK.
A related thing which, I
think, gets to the heart
of what's going on, that humans
can do with these minimal
images and model, at
the moment cannot,
is that we not only recognize
these images and say this is
a man, this is an
eagle, this is a horse.
Once we recognize it,
although the image
itself is sort of atomic, in
the sense that you reduce it
and recognition goes away,
but once we recognize it
we can recognize sort
of subatomic particles.
We can recognize
things inside it.
So if this is a
person, we ask again
in the psychophysical
test to tell us
what you see inside the image
using various methodologies,
which I'll not go into.
But people recognize this.
This is a person
in an Italian suit,
for those of you who
could not recognize it.
But once people
recognize it, they say,
this is the neck of the person.
This is the tie.
This is the knot of the tie.
This is part of the jacket,
and so on and so forth.
I mean, they recognize
a whole lot of details,
semantic internal
details inside.
If they see this is the
horse, the contrast is low,
but they see the ear,
and the other ear,
and the eye, and the mouth.
But if you reduce the image,
they lose the recognition
completely.
Once they recognize it,
they recognize a whole lot
of structure inside.
And I think that the
structure, by itself,
is the more interesting
part, because, really, we
don't want to see a horse.
We don't want to see a car.
We want to know where the car
door is, where the knob is.
We want to recognize all
the internal details.
But the ability to recognize
all of these internal details
is, automatically,
it's also helping you
with improving the
recognition and rejecting
sort of false detections.
Because these are
images the deep network
thought that are good
images of a man in a suit.
But once you dive inside and you
say, where exactly is the neck
and where exactly is the tie,
and is it the right structure
that I expect?
The answer is that it's
not quite appropriate.
And you can use that so that
this internal interpretation
is, first of all, the more
important goal of vision.
But, in addition,
once you do it,
you can reject
things that appeared,
based on the causal structure,
to be correct, and in this way
you can get the
correct recognition.
And, for this
reason, my prediction
is that it will be very
difficult to get it
with current deep network,
because what you'd need
is not only to get the label
out but to be able to dive
down and get the correct
interpretation, and inspect it.
And it has some properties.
The tie, the knot in the
tie is slightly wider
than the part under
it, and so on.
So you have to check for
the-- you know these things
and you check for them.
And if you don't do it,
then the recognition
will remain limited.
Now, when you look at
it and you say, OK,
and we try to develop
an algorithm--
which we'll actually dive
in and we'll do the internal
interpretation, and we'll do
them correctly and we'll reject
false alarms, and so on--
it turns out that this is
an interesting business.
You have to be very
accurate, and some
of the properties and relations
that you need to extract
are very specific to
certain categories
and are very precise.
For example, this was
selected by deep network
as a very good example
of a horse head.
And, basically, it does
have the right shape.
But, for example,
people reject it.
We asked people who did not
accept it as a horse head,
and they said, for example, that
these lines are too straight.
It looks like a man-made
part rather than
a part of a real animal.
That was a repeating
answer, for example.
But deviation, how
straight is it and so on,
this is a bit tricky.
And also it didn't
have quite the ear
that you do expect here.
So we think that the kind of
feature that you need in order
to do this internal
interpretation of interest
depends on relatively
complicated properties
and relations that
you don't want
to spend time and effort
doing in a bottom-up way
all over the entire
visual field.
If certain two contours
smoothly are in a corner,
or if something is really
straight, only semi-straight.
I mean, to do all of these
computations my hunch is,
to do all of these
complicated things,
you need them only in a small--
you need some specific ones
for some specific classes
at some specific locations.
So the right way to do
this kind of computation,
the right architecture,
seems to me
a combination of bottom-up
and top-down processing.
And we know that, in
the visual system--
this is a diagram of
the visual system, which
is supposed to show that we have
lots of connections going up,
but also a lot of
connections going down.
And the suggestion that
I would like to put up--
and I think it's
what's happening here--
is that we have something
like deep network
that does an initial
generic classification.
It's bottom-up.
It has some kind of--
was trained on many categories.
It is not sensitive to all of
these small and informative
things that you need for
internal classification.
And it proposes a lot of-- it
gives you initial recognition,
which is OK.
It's especially OK when you
have a complete object and not
something challenging
like a minimal image.
Because you may be wrong on a
couple of the minimal images,
but you have 20 of
them in each object.
So if two are wrong,
it's not too bad.
So, under many
circumstances, you
will be OK in terms of
general recognition.
But what this does is it
doesn't complete the process,
but it sort of triggers the
application of something which
is much more class-specific,
that it says,
oh, it looks like a horse.
Let's check if it has,
or let's now complete
the interpretation.
It's not just a
validation, but you really
want to know where is the
eye, where is the ear, where
is the mouth, and so on.
You want to know maybe if
the mouth is open or closed.
You want to feed the horse.
You want to pet the horse.
I mean, when you interact with
objects, all of these things
are important.
So you continue
your understanding
of the visual scene.
But this is not this generic
bottom-up recognition,
but you are looking
for specific structures
that you learned about when you
interacted with these objects
before.
And then you test
specific things.
Where is the eye?
There should be a round
thing roughly here,
and so on and so forth.
So these are more
extended routines
that you're applying to
the detected region, sort
of directed from above, and
you know what kind of feature
to look for at
different locations
within the minimal image.
And this kind of ongoing,
continuing interpretation
is not just inside,
internally, to what
you succeeded to recognize,
but sort of spread
over the entire image.
For example, if you
look at this image,
what do you see here
in this image here?
Anyone want to suggest
what we see here?
AUDIENCE: A face, maybe.
SHIMON ULLMAN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: A face.
AUDIENCE: A woman's face.
SHIMON ULLMAN: A woman's face.
What is the woman doing?
AUDIENCE: Drinking.
SHIMON ULLMAN: Drinking.
Right.
So it's a woman drinking,
for those of you
managed to recognize.
This is the woman, and
she's drinking from a cup.
Now, we tested it.
The woman is actually
a minimal image.
If you remove the cup,
you show this image,
people recognize it
at a relatively high.
Nobody recognizes this
is a glass when you just
show the glass on its own.
We think that the actual
recognition process
in your head starts
with recognizing
what is recognizable
on its own, sort
of the minimal configuration
which you know what it is.
You don't need help.
You don't need context.
You don't need anything.
This is a woman.
This is the mouth.
And you can continue from
there in the same way
that you can
recognize internally
that this is the
nose, and the nostril,
and this is the upper
lip and lower lip.
In the same way that you can
guide your interpretation
process internally,
you can also say
that the thing which is docked
at her mouth is a glass.
Some results from--
this has been
implemented by Guy Ben-Yosef,
who is also now a part of CBMM.
And this internal
interpretation begins
to work interestingly well.
We started to do at
MIT some MEG studies,
because if this is correct,
if the interpretation
process and the correct
recognition of minimal images
and the following full
interpretation process
is driven by its--
requires for completion,
it requires the triggering
of top-down processing,
that we could see it using
the right kind of imaging.
In this case, we started to do
minimal images in MEG images.
MEG is-- I think you--
was MEG already mentioned
here in any of the talks?
So MEG, as you know,
it doesn't have
very good spatial resolution.
It's not like fMRI, but it has
very good temporal resolution.
And what Leyla-- it
was led by Leyla Isik.
And what we've
done here is trying
to let subjects in the MEG
recognize minimal images.
And we took the electrodes from
the MEG and trained a decoder.
The decoder is trained
to say whether or not
the image contains, say,
an eagle in this case.
And we had various images.
And the question
is, we can follow
the performance of the
computational decoder that
tries to say now the
image, now the electrode,
the pattern of
electrodes, allow me
to deduce that there is
an eagle in the image.
And we see that the decoder is
successful, you can see here,
at about 400 milliseconds.
This is late for vision.
The initial bottom-up initial
recognition is more like 150,
or something like this.
And we also get the same results
when we do psychophysics,
that in normal images you
can recognize them at--
you can get good
recognition after, say,
exposure of 100 milliseconds
followed by a mask
to recognize correctly
at the human level,
to get to the human
level that we get.
With minimal images,
you have to give
enough time, which we
suspect is enough time,
to allow the application of the
top-down interpretation within.
And if you don't give
enough time, then
people degenerate and
become deep networks,
and you get the same kind
of performance, roughly.
But this is all still
unpublished and still running,
and we need more subjects.
And all of this is looking
in the right direction,
and looking in providing
support for top-down processing
for this.
And this, by the
way, it's interesting
methodologically, because
it's very difficult.
With real images, it's so rich
and you get so much information
already in the way
of going up and
because of these redundancies,
that even if you make
20% error, it doesn't really
matter because you have
redundancy, you
have many multiple,
sufficient minimal images
within any object, and so on.
So it's very
difficult to tease out
the effect of where exactly the
top-down information starts.
Where do you need it?
Where exactly you fail
if you don't have it.
So we think you need it for
this internal interpretation
and for the correct
recognition of minimal images.
And here you can start seeing
good signals in the MEG.
It provides you sort of a
tool that is pretty unique
and allows you to
do these things.
So let me add what is
a very informal thing
but where I think this is going.
I think that when you
look at difficult images,
like action recognition
that we discussed below,
many things that we
do depend not on sort
of cause label of there
is a person there,
or there is an airplane,
or there is a dog.
But, really, things
depend on the fine details
of the internal interpretation.
And so if you can
turn off what I
think is the top-down part
of class-specific top-down
processes, I think that many
of these fine distinctions
that we make all the time-- and
it's what vision is all about.
Vision is not about
giving cause categories--
will go away.
And so these things will
become more and more
an important part of vision.
Let me look at this variability
in action recognition.
But let me show you
some specific examples.
This is something that
confuses current classifiers,
that in most of them it seems
that the person is drinking.
Because there is a
person, there is a bottle,
and the bottle is
close to the mouth.
So the person is drinking
at this rough level
of description.
But, obviously, here
this person is drinking,
this person is pouring, right?
Something very-- is this
person drinking at the moment?
Yes or no?
AUDIENCE: No.
SHIMON ULLMAN: No.
Why not?
She's holding a cup, and
it's not far, and maybe
on the way to the mouth.
We know that she's
not drinking, right?
But why exactly not?
And, again, this
is something that
is picked up as drinking by
many recognition systems.
But something is wrong here.
All of these things, these
are different objects
and different actions that
the people are performing.
This is drinking from a straw.
This is smoking.
And this is brushing
their teeth.
But this depends on, you have
to go to the right location
and decide exactly
what's happening there.
It's the kind of thing
that we do all the time.
Some more challenges.
These are just sort
of informal challenges
to show you how we can deal with
fine interpretation of details
of interest in the image.
What is this arrow pointing at?
AUDIENCE: Bottle
SHIMON ULLMAN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Bottle.
SHIMON ULLMAN: Yeah.
But above the bottle, there
is something else there.
AUDIENCE: Fingers.
SHIMON ULLMAN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Finger.
SHIMON ULLMAN: Fingers, right.
Let's see.
Just playing this time.
What is this arrow pointing at?
AUDIENCE: Zipper.
SHIMON ULLMAN: Zipper.
Let's see.
Here are two challenging things.
Here are two arrows.
What is this one pointing at?
AUDIENCE: Cup?
AUDIENCE: Tea.
AUDIENCE: Cup.
SHIMON ULLMAN: All right.
Next to the cup,
right, is also--
this is really challenging.
Let's see if some folks.
What is this one pointing at?
AUDIENCE: A tray?
AUDIENCE: A tray.
SHIMON ULLMAN: Tray.
So the tray, think
about it, it's this,
but you match it with this thing
here in order to make sure,
to know that it's a tray.
It's not something that
will be easily picked up.
I mean, I'm looking for
difficult things which
are a little bit challenging.
And you say, ah, I can get it.
But this level of detail,
interpreting the fine details
and images in a top-down
fashion happens all the time.
Is this person smoking?
Of course not, and we
are not fooled by it,
and we immediately zoom
on the right things.
And, really, all the information
is here at the end of the--
and so on, and so
on, and so forth.
I mean, we were looking
at dealing visually
with social interactions,
understanding
the social interactions
between agents.
And, again, it's very
difficult to do correctly,
and it depends on subtle things.
I mean, you can get
something rough OK.
For example, is this
sort of an intimate hug,
or this just a cordial hug
of people who are not--
we know exactly what's
going on, right?
And it turns out that
the features are not
that easy to get.
This was picked up
incorrectly by something
that we designed
for people hugging.
And it's not very far
from people hugging,
but it doesn't fool us, right?
But they are not really hugging.
On social interactions,
we know interactions
even between non-human agents.
I mean, this
interaction, is this
is threatening interaction
or a friendly interaction?
What do you think?
Yeah.
Correct.
I think so too.
Anyway, I think that all of
these things that we can do,
and I think that
vision is about this.
It's not about
looking at this room
and saying that this is a
computer and this is a chair.
It's about understanding
the situation
and making fine judgments,
and interacting with objects.
And, in fact, we're looking at
is part of we're doing at CBMM.
We are looking at the problem of
asking questions about images.
So we want a system
that you can give it
an image and a
question, and then we
want the system to be able
to process the image in such
a way that will give you a
good answer to the question.
This is interesting
because it means
that it's not just a
generic pipeline of running
the image through a
pipeline, sort of fixed
sequence of operations.
But, depending on what
you're interested in,
the whole visual process should
be directed in a particular way
to produce just the
relevant answer.
And we looked at a set of--
with students, we looked at
a set of some 600 questions
that we gave people on the
Mechanical Turk images.
And we say imagine some
questions about these images.
Ask some question
about these images.
And they came up
with some images.
We looked at them, and
an informal observation,
initial observation, is
that most of these questions
that people invented
to ask about images,
you needed some
things which depended
on precise internal
interpretation of the details.
So it's things that
come up all the time.
You have to dive into
the image and analyze
the subtle cues that will tell
you that these are not hugging,
and this is not threatening,
and this is not an intimate hug,
and so on and so forth.
And this is what we are--
the whole story of
the minimal images
and the internal interpretation.
The real goal
eventually is to be
able to identify the important
visual features and structures
which are important
for this, and thinking
about the automatic
learning of how to extract
the internal structure
that will support
the interpretation of all these
interesting and meaningful
aspects of images that, at
the moment, we do not have.
OK, let me skip this.
OK, I think I've said all
of these conclusions already
in the final comments,
so let me stop here.